[Musique]
moins connue dans le circuit touristique
albertains pourtant c'est magnifique et
c'est un site qui nous permet de mieux
comprendre l'histoire des prix on y
découvre l'histoire des pieds-noirs une
nation autochtone donc ça coco tôt notre
guide dans le parc c'est parti
les cycliques et ses tapis était l'un
des groupes les plus puissants des
grandes plaines leur territoire
comprenait le sud de l'alberta de la
saskatchewan nord du montana aussi au
début du 19e siècle
il aurait réussi à stopper
temporairement l'expansion européenne
vers l'ouest et c'est leur histoire
qu'ils ont des peines directement sur la
rue le parc comprend des centaines de
petroglyph certains mieux préservées que
d'autres
laura une autre guide qui est passionné
d'archéologie nous emmène voir des
dessins lieu de 500 la roche sur
laquelle est dessinée est composé
essentiellement de sable et d'argile
donc assez friable on trouve aussi dans
le parc des centaines de oud ou des
cheminées de fées comme on les appelle
en français
des colonnes naturel de roches qui ont
mis des millions d'années à se former
grâce à l'érosion et qui ont une
signification particulière pour les
pieds-noirs et si vous avez envie de
passer plus de temps entouré de ses
esprits qui veille sur les lieux depuis
des siècles le parc est ouvert au campo
si leur en partie radio canada à 1000
coureurs dans ceux de l'alberta